wins a battle down in the corner against Brandon
s KY burough works it over to the left Point S A
Bouncing Puck gathered back in by Ean in Arizon he
scored his first NHL goal in his first NHL game a
night when the Sharks scored seven near the end of
the regular season against the desert dogs there's
a save by Hofer now it's picked up at the point by
emberson ster cross they score Mike Hoffman that's
his second straight game with a goal and it's one-
nothing [Applause] sharks good exit out of the
zone and then everybody working together all five
guys up Yan Ruda pushes it back deep supporting
the puck and look at the two-on-one created by
the Sharks why because they're reading off of
each other they're continuing to move what a nice
little play by Nico Sturm Nik St term sells that
he's going to the net throws a beautiful pass
across and might works his way in gets wide on
Justin fa but then faul recovered in time aotu
will bounce this one in on net by emberson rims
that one hard but hoper off his line able to
control it for the blues now in comes Addison
and kayin Addison put one right on Target and now
duclair that's knocked Away by Ley Burrows follows
he'll press it into the zone takes a wrist shot
hope will glove it but he'll have to step aside as
he gets tossed out of the circle by linesman Ben
oquinn Sharks win it anyway and a quick shot from
Addison off the draw another face off that ends up
on a defenseman stick Yan Ruda testing part of the
foundation of the future for the St Louis team a
chance for kaanan and kakenan comes up with his
first save and it's a beauty that's what did that
hit almost hit javanni Smith here's cunan again
his onetime handled by hord a link whistle so
javanni Smith came in there took another poke nice
guy but not not a happy face that was not a happy
face from javanni Smith eckan in front hurdle off
his sticking just wide the team up on the wall
there this is granin he'll come in with duclair
he'll put it on and it's gloved down by the goal
tender Hofer Sturm wins the draw sharks go back to
work Ferraro and that one's knocked Away by Hofer
up into the netting that's a 1230 game against
Montreal here's pavic and coo kakin and makes a
glove save as bnic as Ruda now will try and get
it out of the Zone duclair turned back and he gave
it away to Thomas didn't see him into C it and
he couldn't caral it you see Craig Ruby there the
head coach last Saturday night won his 200th game
as head coach of the St Louis Blues save by Hofer
Rana to cre down low it's sunfist sunfist default
coming off the bench make it Sammy blle his shot
didn't get much on it and then kin comes across
coming back and taking away the middle they do a
nice job on letting the goalie see it good work
coming down and collapsing down low but you've got
to get your stick in to Rob K another good save
for cppo hasn't seen a lot incoming and he stops
another one here no rebound available for Oscar
sun was sitting on that doorstep they were moving
together they were getting pucks behind the D they
were working as a unit now they're just going to
get back to make sure they control the puck quick
shot by sunas off the draw there now back to the
Blue Line Bal looking for a tip out at the side
of the net he's got sunfist and Neighbors there
now blade he's bumped by Carpenter they re-engage
pass works all the way back out to the line fault
measur shoots aing with the save number 48 good
jobu that's turned over and now sunquist in
alone for the blues shoots and it's saved by
kinen we in your Zone this kind of stuff but
give credit to Capo K and here's on the initi
make that visit and thank to our friends at
Kaiser Permanente shoot that puck right off
the bat shoot that puck here's a hook you and
he scores it's tipped at the front of the net
and the sharks get off to a great start here in
the second period it's two to nothing right off
the bat good entry into the Zone they don't
have to skate too far they ice got a little
bit short there just missing on that chance but
they stay on it and this is not a great great
play by the blues to throw it to that weak side
outstanding positioning in front look at the head
up Paca bounces into period number two
two nothing sharks Shen he's got Brandon
s kicked out by gaken just about got the third
goal right there here's Burrows he'll lob it
down into the corner Carpenter up the
middle cunning to Smith he's SC [Music]
javani Smith his first goal as a shark it's three
nothing well there's the smile that Mario Ferraro
didn't get in the first period again for check
by the Sharks two guys there release get back
underneath inside position stay with the puck
javanni Smith comes off the boards after making
the play and then goes to the net rebounder loose
Puck opportunity shovels it home the great
thing guys the bench exploded you love the
tough guy javanni Smith the 300th different
player to score a goal with the sharks going
back here's cunan he [Music] scores that line
does It Again Luke cunan has a three-game goal
scoring streak sh up four nothing face off have
been strong for the San Jose Sharks this season
and they stay on it right there the Sharks
probably get away with a trip by Luke cunan
sharks stay on it and Luke what does he do AF
to play at the Blue Line yeah you got away with
one but then he continues to attack the net
comes out on his stick off his stick timeout
by Craig Ru here's neighbors and it's blocked
by a hook a lead pass for Hopman he's in 11 and
scor Mike Hoffman and it's five
nothing what a play right there to get inside
and make the pass off the ey off to up to Mike
hofflin I should say work to get inside right work
to get inside and then Mike Hoffman quick rer look
at that stick Flex absolutely beautiful Hayes
out front and granin trying to find it there's
a great save by kinan and another two outstanding
stops at home against Tampa in a 5- nothing win
this past Tuesday the sharks have turned the
table so far here tonight there's a shot in
the goal and the shut out spoiled for Capo kinan
as Justin faul fires one and it finds its way in
51 Justin Faulk is looking for the shot pass all
the way as the sharks have it in the corner they
look like they're in control they don't get it out
though Zena is a little weak on that play and then
look at how the setup is for that pass push navit
in front was that who got it definitely deflected
right there look at the stick right he's looking
for that top shelf he lifted it up too high back
down to and through denied there by Capo ginan
three periods strung together scored once in
the first and then blew it out in the second
period they win it here with ease and coo kinan
picks up his first win of this season and his
first since April of last year with the sharks